I'm gonna try and capture contain and
investigate a higher dimensional sphere
starting with a circle so if we begin in
2d you've come across circles before
they look you know roughly like that
we're gonna try and contain a circle so
we can look at how big it can be so what
I'm gonna do is start with a box four by
four for reasons I'll explain about it
so that's four units that way it's four
units that way and now I'm going to put
some safety padding spheres in there so
if you kind of measure if I was to
actually split this into quarters I'm
gonna put safety fears
well they're their circles I'm gonna
call them spheres no matter what
dimension they're in right so when I say
sphere I mean two DS fear it's a circle
so I'm not very good at drawing circles
so they're there be one there and it
just touches it kisses all four sides of
that box there'd be one there which just
touches or is that just context that's
sphere so that just contacts there and
that one just contacts there
and so that's adequate okay that's
little do it'll do they're not
overlapping apart so meanwhile so this
is why I made the box four by four
because it means these in a unit spheres
or unit circles so they all have a
radius that's one in that direction one
they've all got one in every every
direction I'm now gonna see what is the
biggest circle I can fit in the middle
so I've got my containing box I've got
my padding spheres or circles I've now
got this is the subject this is the one
we care about and I'm now going to try
and fit the biggest circle possible in
the middle so how big is that circle
well there's the very middle of a box
here is the center of this padding
circle over here we know that's one that
way that's one that way so what we have
if we zoom in a little bit so that
complete length there that whole thing
is root 2 and that there is one that's a
little bit there is root 2 minus 1 which
equals around about 0.4 1/4 so that's
the biggest circle we can fit in the
middle in 2d onwards upwards to 3d for
3d we would have a Q
with eight padding spheres and so I've
brought oranges these are the the
cheapest spheres I could find in the
grocery store and so that that's the
rough equivalent of what we had before
you know I only think they can you know
I guess I'm gonna tape them play yeah
and those go on there so I haven't got
the containing box but you can imagine
that there is the base is still four by
four that we had previously
that's four in every direction but now
as well as four by four we'd have
another length up here so we'd have
another dimension this way which is also
four and then here's the top of our four
by four box and we can fit twice as many
see as in as last time so four spheres
in 2d eight spheres in 3d and you can
see again there's a gap in the middle
right so inside our box is that our
padding spheres in there is a void and
the question is what is the biggest 3d
sphere that we can fit inside inside
there here are four adequate you know
that okay so that's back on yeah they're
getting to know each other very well and
so who am I to judge so that is like the
cross-section in here that lines up with
the middle of the bottom layer of
spheres so what we've done already is
for the center point here in the middle
we know from the middle of this one it's
one across to get there it's one up to
get there and so that diagonal was root
two and then before we subtracted off
the radius just to get the difference
there but now we want to we need to go
one aren't we to go up as well and again
it's another quarter of the whole box so
we have to go up a single unit and so we
do Pythagoras with that our base is now
root two and then our height is one and
so to work out what that is root 2
squared is 2 one squared is one that
there is root three and actually
Pythagoras generalizes to any number of
dimensions it's just the square of all
that if
orthogonal directions take the square
atom together take the square root very
straight forwards that's gonna make our
lives very easy going forward and once
again that diagonal we want the
difference between the radius of the
sphere and what's left and so I knew
radius of the biggest sphere we can fit
in there is root 3 minus 1 which equals
0.732 you know 0 5 some stuff ok
so actually it's slightly bigger and
that kind of makes sense because you
know there's not much room there to fit
a circle in there's a little bit more
space in there because you know the more
directions you can go in the question
now is what happens in in 4d what
happens in 5d if we keep going up and up
and up and up and up what's the maximum
size the box is never getting any bigger
it's always four in every direction the
spheres are never getting any bigger the
packing spheres are always radius one
the middle sphere is always inside the
void left between the box which isn't
getting bigger it's getting more
directions within it but it's not
getting bigger lengths and the spheres
which again they're going more
directions but they're not getting
bigger and a sphere is always in any
dimension all the points which are the
same distance from some central point
you just have more directions in which
that can happen so this is the dimension
D that we're currently working in and
this is the radius of the middle fear in
dimension D so we've already done the
first couple we in 2d it was zero point
4 1 4 2 1 3 D which we just did the zero
point seven three two zero four D it's
still the square of one square of one
square of one square of one for the
fourth direction add them together take
the square root which is two that's not
so straightforward so in fact the radius
of the central sphere in 4d is root 4
which is 2 minus 1 which is 1 so now the
middle fear has exactly the same radius
as the padding spheres around it so
there will be 16 padding spheres in 4d
and the single one in the middle is
exactly the same size
awesome SP is pretty cool 4d lovely
stuff happens
5d let's see what happens you have now
got 32 padding spheres the box is 4 in
all our 5 different directions and the
middle one has a radius of 1 point 2 3 6
oh it's now it's bigger the middle one
is is bigger than the other ones around
it that's odd
let's keep going in six dimensions it is
one point four four nine four bunch of
stuff a little bit bigger again but
hopefully slowing down seven dimensions
one point six four five seven eight
dimensions one point eight two eight
four nine dimensions it's two so in
ninety the middle spear has the same
radius as the distance from its center
to the outside of the containing box so
in ninety the middle sphere has just
contacted the outer surface of the box
it's it's somehow got past the padding
spheres which are all over it it's got
through them even though it's limited by
them like that they define how big it is
it's not allowed to touch them it's that
it kisses them it doesn't just not going
through them somehow it's big enough
that it's contacting the box without
going through the spheres touching it
and in 10d slightly disturbingly
it escapes the box completely it's now
two point one six two so as of ten
dimensions and indeed ten dimensions
onwards it is bigger than the original
box which was containing it I mean the
short moral of the story is that higher
dimensional spheres are really weird and
difficult to contain how are you
reconciling this in your head how does
it make sure there's a trick you can use
in mathematics called not worrying about
it everything we have learnt no longer
really works and so people who do have
to come to grips with higher dimensional
spheres will describe them as being
spiky higher dimensional spheres are
spiky there's some of those spikes are
making it out of the box like that ship
that Superman went up in in the original
Superman movie that I mean I was trying
to think of a good
sample which everyone will be able to
you know really connect with and I think
you've nailed it with that 70s Superman
reference if I remember the fill well
good job good job I can see how you're
the master of bringing science to the
masses Brady you put I'll get you
putting a picture on the screen good boy
good boy no yes so so imagine that
imagine your favorite film with the
spiky thing in it it's a bit like that
people don't get hung up on that so you
just go high dimensional spheres a spiky
and our word spiky is not perfect but in
some way it grasps what's going on in
higher dimensions it just turns out the
more dimensions the sphere is in the
point here it gets well somewhat
appropriately this video about fitting
circles and spheres into a square space
has been brought to you by Squarespace
Squarespace is the ultimate online
service for creating and managing
websites I use it myself for various
projects including blogs calculator
unboxings of course and podcasts if
you've got a bright idea something you
want to share with the world maybe a
website all about spiky spherical
objects in movies then you really need
to be checking out Squarespace they make
everything easy from choosing a domain
picking a great template to get started
and making sure your site looks good on
all devices you can try before you buy
setting up a site for free just to make
sure it's as good as I'm saying you want
to go to squarespace.com slash
numberphile and that's going to get you
10% off your first domain or website
there's the address up there
squarespace.com slash numberphile
you